let's go
to kelly who joins us in portland oregon
kelly how can we help
hey there hey dave thanks for taking my
call sure
it's ken and anthony how can we help hey
so
well um pretty just simple simple uh
way to go about this is uh my long story
short i should say
is my boyfriend and i have been together
for two and a half years
and we want to get married but um
something has come up with his dad
and threatening basically kind of
threatening him
saying that if we get married then he
wants us to pay his parent plus one that
he took out for a son
and i thought that um you know i'm not
me and i wouldn't be responsible for
that correct if we did end up getting
married is that correct
no you personally what is the parent
plus loan how much money what is it what
are the conditions of it
um well he actually took out
two loans for him and his sister um
so all together equals about like 70 000
altogether
um but he's saying that if he were to
pass away
um it would go on to his you know his
wife
so uh my boyfriend's mom and then his
mom would be left with the debt and so
he's
kind of making him feel bad that if he
does this you know and leaving the debt
um no i understand that part my question
is i've not heard of this anthony uh do
you know what a parent plus
i mean is it absolutely is is the
boyfriend's name on the loan well i mean
it all depends it could be in some
majority times it's not
in this case is it yeah no his name's
not on it no
so legally legally
you and your uh boyfriend are covered
now
morally you have to have an honest
conversation with your boyfriend and ask
them hey
did you and your father have a
conversation saying that if i take out
this loan
you will pay me back or was it your dad
saying hey i'm gonna take out the loan
and this is gonna be my portion going
towards
your education so legally you are
covered so don't stress over that part
now you got to go back to the moral
perspective what was the
what was the agreement kelly um
he just his dad never really actually
had an agreement he was actually
at the time being trying to be helpful
what did he take the loan out for
college um it was at
a four-year university yeah okay all
right
but um and then my boyfriend also has
federal student loans and if we were to
get married i was
afraid would that go on to me too if
something were to happen
and you know i'm just thinking ahead as
well all right so here's what
all right ao i i've heard enough yeah
i think you broke it down very well as
far as this goes but i don't like dad's
move here i don't like dad
um you how old are you kelly and how old
is your boyfriend
i'm 26 he's 33. all for heaven's sakes
your boyfriend's a grown man or at least
he should be acting like one he should
tell his dad to back off
now wait wait no no you don't get to
hold that over
you do not get to hold that over your 33
year old son and say if you marry this
girl
then then then i'm changing all the
terms you don't get to do that
this is a broken relationship and this
needs to get figured out
i agree i'm just saying before we say
that we got to ask the question to both
father and son to see what they agreed
to
verbally but i don't think kelly knows
there was any agreement at all i do i
think the son needs to pay the dad back
yes but it doesn't allow dad to say
you can't get married or i'm gonna ask
for all of it up front
it sounds to me like it's a threat yeah
that's foolishness
is he saying that yeah
that's what he's saying man yeah now i'm
with you give me some love right there
what do you think i'm doing over here
listen listen
here's what needs to happen you and your
boyfriend need to sit down and go
are we in this for the long haul i hope
you are
yeah and then you your boyfriend needs
to say first of all you need to not
worry about this isn't between you
you just need to support your boyfriend
but the boyfriend needs to say to dad
listen i don't appreciate this if this
is a threat
that's really bad we need to get that
figured out and if you don't want to
figure that out i'm going to pay you
back
and here's the plan yeah i'm coming up
with a plan or here is a plan i'm going
to pay you back but this
you got to pay me back right away or all
this garbage that's a bunch of nonsense
and your boyfriend needs to step up he's
33 he needs to be a man
and he needs to pay dad back and kelly
you you don't say nothing
yeah you you you and your husband you
and your boyfriend you all have a
conversation
and you let your father you let your
boyfriend go to his father
and if his father comes to you you keep
your mouth shut you say you deal with
that with your son
i don't know i tell the father yeah you
need to stay out
thanksgiving is not gonna be fun anyway
so
we're starting out on a really really
rough situation
uh this is this you know there's a book
your boyfriend you need to get this
here's what you need to do buy the book
boundaries by dr henry mccloud
and give that to your boyfriend you all
read that together the audience is
shaking their head
can i get an amen out there they're
saying yeah this is this is ugly stuff
um but uh this is a good old-fashioned
father-son
sit down and let's let's act like men
and get this thing figured out
boy that's a